bonsoir vous personnes âgées
vous n'êtes pas une catégorie à part
dans la société française vous avez
droit comme les autres à participer à la
vie commune des français
c'est en résumé le thème principal du
discours prononcé cet après midi par
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing à la
fin de la première rencontre nationale
du troisième âge à lyon en fait on l'a
bien senti qu'au delà des dix mille
personnes qui étaient venues écouter le
chef de l'état le président de la
république s'est directement adressé aux
7 millions de français âgés de plus de
65 ans dans sa déclaration le président
de la république a fait d'une part le
bilan de l'action du gouvernement en
faveur du troisième âge et promis
également de nouvelles mesures qui
devraient permettre d'améliorer leurs
conditions
les personnes âgées sont près du coeur
de la france elles font partie de la
communauté fraternelle des français
ce n'est pas une catégorie à part
retranché de la vie sociale sur le sort
de laquelle les autres se pencherait les
personnes âgées sont pour moi un groupe
de françaises et de français comme les
autres
parmi les autres et qui doivent
participer sur un pied d'égalité et de
respect à la vie commune des français
leur situation veut souvent qu'elle ait
besoin de recevoir ce n'est qu'une juste
compensation des efforts qu'elles ont
fourni
mais je sais qu'elles ont aussi beaucoup
pas donner parce qu'elles ont une
expérience une sagesse
une générosité dont la france a besoin
puis le président de la république a
rappelé les engagements qu'il avait pris
et qui ont été tenus pour une personne
seule le minimum vieillesse était de
5200 francs avant son élection il sera
de onze mille francs le 1er décembre
prochain il aura donc doublé et il
atteindra 12 mille francs en 78 une
personne seule avec 14 cents quarante
par jour en 74 en or à 30 cette année 33
l'an prochain les retraités de 5000 les
retraites de 5 millions de pensionnés
ont augmenté de près de 60 % en trois
ans ce qui représente 18 et demi
pourcent d'accroissement de leur pouvoir
d'achat réel en matière de fiscalité les
impôts de ceux qui viennent de prendre
leur retraite et dont les ressources se
trouvent réduites seront allégées et
l'ensemble des retraités bénéficiera
d'un abattement accrue justifiée par les
charges du troisième âge pour les veuves
et les veufs le cumul d'une pension
personnelle et d'une pension de
reversions a été autorisé dans des
limites qui seront progressivement
élargi pour pallier la solitude des
personnes âgées celles ci n'auront plus
à payer la taxe de raccordement du
téléphone enfin pour comme dit le
président briser leur isolement
il faut que les personnes âgées puissent
avoir des relations avec les autres il
est donc indispensable qu'elles aient la
possibilité d'alerter un voisin un
parent en cas de besoin et c'est pour
cela qu'il faut mettre en place un
système d'alarmé téléphonique décidé de
faciliter l'accès au téléphone des deux
millions de personnes âgées
qui perçoivent le minimum vieillesse
désormais elles seront dispensés de la
taxe de raccordement de 800 francs
perçus lors de l'installation du
téléphone par ailleurs les personnes
âgées de plus de 65 ans bénéficieront
d'une priorité accrue pour
l'installation du téléphone à leur
domicile avec une super priorité
immédiate pour les personnes de plus de
80 ans
pour l'avenir j'ai demandé au secrétaire
d'état aux couettes et
télécommunications la mise à l'étude de
la création progressive à partir des
expériences actuellement en cours et à
partir de 1981 qui est la date
nécessaire pour prévoir les
installations d'un réseau national de
téléalarme pour les personnes âgées
ce réseau pourraient être
progressivement étendue à plusieurs
millions d'abonnés isolement physique
mais aussi isolement moral notre société
ne doit pas être une société de solitude
je souhaite que de toutes parts les
initiatives se multiplient pour
faciliter les relations enrichissantes
et confiance et c'était le sujet
essentiel de vos assises tels que
monsieur rené lenoir vient de nous en
rendre compte
à cet égard les personnes âgées donne
l'exemple puisque beaucoup d'entre elles
puisque beaucoup d'entre vous ont décidé
de sortir elle même de leur isolement
il faut savoir qu'en septembre le nombre
de vos clubs a été multiplié par dix et
que désormais il regroupe deux millions
de personnes
il faut aller plus loin et poser le
problème dans sa véritable dimension
les personnes âgées comme les autres
catégories de notre société ne s'y
sentiront à leur place que si elles ont
le sentiment d'y jouer un rôle actif
l'unité de notre société française je ne
la veux pas seulement dans le domaine
politique et sociale je la veux aussi
dans le domaine des générations la
rapidité des changements de la vie
moderne
la mobilité géographique et
professionnelle
l'évolution de la famille
tout cela a contribué à l'éclatement des
générations et au cloisonnement des âges
il est essentiel de retrouver l'unité
regardez-vous d'ailleurs les unes et les
autres
ces assises qui vous rapproche vous aide
à mesurer combien malgré la diversité
vos problèmes vos aspirations vos
réactions deviennent progressivement
semblable à l'autre extrémité de la
société française
regardons la jeunesse et nous voyons
aussi combien les jeunes veulent être
semblable entre eux
combien ils refusent les différences
excessive
combien ils rejettent les injustices aux
deux extrémités de l'âge
la société française tant vers l'unité
ainsi ainsi votre expérience et votre
exemple peuvent-ils aider la société
française dans sa marche vers l'unité
marche nécessaires et dont on aperçoit
aujourd'hui les filles
le président de la république en
s'adressant cet après midi aux 10000
personnes âgées et à travers elle à
toutes les générations avaient choisi de
parler le langage du ter et de la
fraternité
on retrouve une fois de plus dans ce
discours moralisateur la trame des
préoccupations qu'il affectionne depuis
le début de son septennat à savoir qu'il
faut savoir conduire les changements
nécessaires et notamment faire en sorte
que dans une société trop matérialiste
les personnes âgées trouvent la place
qui leur revient de droit
de la même façon il s'est attaché à
démontrer la nocivité d'une société
coupés en deux comme d'une france coupée
en deux c'est sur ce thème que le chef
de l'état paraît avoir placé une fois
pour toute son action
et même si certains la jugent
électoraliste il paraît avoir décidé de
s'en tenir là
six morts six femmes de nationalité
espagnole et une vingtaine de blessés
dans un terrible accident de car ce
matin à bordeaux le manque d'éclairage
et lampadaires arraché la semaine
dernière par un poids lourd
la pluie une voiture qui a gêné le
conducteur ce sont sans aucun doute les
trois causes de cet accident qui s'est
produit vers 23h20 la nuit dernière à la
sortie de l'autoroute a63 près de
bordeaux
pas de collision un coup de frein
malheureux sur une chaussée détrempée et
glissante
c'était le tête à queue et pour finir le
car s'est retrouvé sur le toit
quarante cinq personnes à bord des
espagnols revenante belgique et rentrant
au pays
six femmes sont mortes dans cet accident
qui a fait aussi 20 blessés le chauffeur
espagnol de cet autocar belge employé
d'une société bruxelloise n'était
pourtant pas un débutant
ces explications permettront sans doute
de déterminer exactement les
responsabilités l'accident s'est produit
la nuit dernière à la sortie de
l'autoroute a63 bordeaux bayonne tout
près de cestas les 20 blessés ont pu
aujourd'hui repartir pour l'espagne avec
leurs dix neuf compagnons de voyage
épargné eux par la malchance à lille
l'explosion d'une conduite de gaz a fait
neuf blessés également la nuit dernière
sept sapeurs pompiers et deux employés
du gaz de france pour la plupart ils ont
été brûlés au moment où il s'apprêtait à
colmater une fuite dans une conduite des
servantes un immeuble hlm
les services de sécurité ont dû creuser
dans un trottoir pour atteindre la
conduite de gaz car apparemment il n'y
avait aucune vannes d'arrêt à l'entrée
de l'immeuble concorde
les autorités de l'aéroport de new york
et alfred hitchcock même combat devenant
de plus en plus spécialiste du suspense
après avoir en avoir appelé à la cour
suprême pour empêcher concorde a tiré à
new york
il est maintenant question que les
autorités lui accorde une période
d'essai de trois mois au moins les
organisations de riverains qui ont une
nouvelle fois manifesté aujourd'hui aux
abords de l'aéroport
leur hostilité au supersonique franco
anglais n'ont pas bougé d'un pouce elle
au contraire par trois mois pas trois
jours par trois minutes pas de concorde
due to a new york
jamais ont-ils déclaré une affaire à
suivre l'espace on s'y attendait depuis
le 29 septembre dernier date de la mise
en orbite de la station saliou ciss les
soviétiques ont bien lancé ce matin un
vaisseau cosmique soyouz 25 avec à bord
deux cosmonautes
à l'américaine avec le drapeau national
au premier plan voici la fusée qui
emporte soyouz 25
c'est la même fusée à quelques détails
près qu'il y a 20 ans l'ensa de ce même
endroit le premier satellite artificiel
de la terre le spoutnik
à bord deux bleus de l'espace l'adie
merkava leenock 35 ans le commandant il
est à droite et à gauche valérie rio
mines 39 ans ingénieur de bord ils
tiennent en sa main droite
un épais livre le texte de la nouvelle
constitution soviétique
il devrait rejoindre la station soyouz 6
dans quelques jours
georges lautner quel est l'intérêt de
cette mission que vont ils faire je vous
fais remarquer que ryu mines a terminé à
l'institut très spécialisés de moscou
l'institut des études et des techniques
forestières
à mon avis la seule la station solide
suisse peut avoir plein d'expériences
scientifiques mais à mon avis ils vont
faire des ressources terrestres vérifier
l'agriculture la pêche les récoltes et
cetera à bord de sa lutte si les photos
je pense avec des photos avec des plus
que les photos des tas de caméras
spécialisé vous sauver il ya quelques
jours la france à lancer un nouveau
satellite pas à lancer l'étude d'un
nouveau satellite au spot pour le même
genre d'expérience voyez c'est vraiment
très très important puis un dernier mot
nous sommes à la veille du 60e
anniversaire de la révolution d'octobre
alors probablement ils vont essayer de
battre un record par exemple la durée de
vie en orbite terrestre qui est
aujourd'hui de 84 jours merci georges
leclercq monsieur ismaël famille le
ministre égyptien des affaires
étrangères doit rencontrer demain à
l'elysée monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing
il est porteur dit on d'un important
message du président sadate autre
visiteur de marque attendus la semaine
prochaine à paris le maréchal tito il
commencera mercredi sa visite officielle
en france
en prévision de cette visite semble-t-il
une vingtaine de citoyens yougoslave en
france ont été assignés à résidence
aujourd'hui dans l'île de porquerolles
comme l'avait été d'ailleurs il ya
quelques temps certains militants
basques en espagne
l'aide militaire l'aide militaire de
letea l'organisation séparatiste basque
a revendiqué ce matin l'assassinât du
président de l'assemblée de biscaye
monsieur oops et a abattu hier à coups
de mitraillette avec ses deux gardes du
corps
ce triple assassinat qui a provoqué une
grande émotion dans tout le pays a été
condamnée elle
unanimité par tous les partis politiques
y compris le gouvernement basque en exil
il devrait permettre à monsieur suarez
le premier ministre de conclure plus
rapidement le pacte de salut public
qu'il a entrepris de négocier avec
l'opposition espagnole pendant ce
week-end deux journaux hollandais
viennent de recevoir à leur tour une
nouvelle lettre et une photo de monsieur
cela hier le patron des patrons
ouest-allemand qui reprochent aux
autorités de bonne de ne pas avoir
entrepris de réelle démarche pour
obtenir sa libération
la situation devient insupportable dit
dans cette lettre monsieur chayer
silence à bonn pour l'instant pas de
réaction du gouvernement fédéral
en revanche madame cela hier par
l'intermédiaire du quotidien bild
zeitung publiée demain demande à son
mari de tenir bon la politique en france
elle a été marqué avant tout par de
réunion ce week-end d'abord le congrès
extraordinaire du cds à lyon avec ce
matin un échange d'amabilités entre
monsieur raymond barre et les
congressistes accepter mes voeux pour le
succès de votre action politique a
expliqué raymond barre dans un message
aux démocrates sociaux réponse de jean
lecanuet nous vous assurons du soutien
de notre mouvement
cela dit sur le fond la journée a été
essentiellement marquée par un discours
très enlevée disons de monsieur lecanu
est réélu président du cds et qui entend
souffler depuis le début de saison
congrès une sorte de contestation à
l'intérieur de son mouvement il a donc
pris les devants en précisant clairement
l'originalité du centrisme dont tant
d'autres voudraient nous arracher
l'étiquette à l'étiquette qui compte
c'est ce qu'il ya derrière l'étiquette
c'est le contenu
le centrisme
c'est une volonté de dépassement de
synthèse et d'élargissement
ce n'est pas une l2 je ne sais quel
major c'est beaucoup plus
voulez-vous que nous passions un pas de
plus dans la connaissance de nous mêmes
et dans la vision des autres sur nous
mêmes le centrisme n'est authentique
qu'à travers le projet d'une démocratie
sociale sans pesanteur conservatrice une
fois de plus on peut dire qu'un congrès
centristes auraient été marquée par un
discours tous ces jours ci monsieur le
calme et paraissait menacé menacé par
une base qui souhaitaient le
renouvellement du parti et qui
souhaitait également le renouvellement
de ses dirigeants
messieurs le canoë paraissait menacé
aussi par tous et tiraillements qui
s'était produit ces temps ci au sein de
son mouvement
ce matin il a repris les choses en main
faisant applaudir vigoureusement par
toute la salle monsieur raymond barre
frappant fort sur monsieur mitterrand
égratignant au passage
monsieur chirac ironisant de temps en
temps sur le parti républicain monsieur
lecanu et a surtout voulu définir ce
qu'était le cds et plus encore le
centrisme et quelle était la place du
centrisme dans la majorité
le centrisme me reste donc ne peut être
que dans la majorité mais il affirme au
sein de cette majorité
le droit à la différence il doit
proposer une politique sociale la
démocratie sociale susceptible de
concurrencer le parti socialiste et puis
il doit aussi éviter de se laisser
absorber monsieur lecanu et a parlé avec
beaucoup de vivacité au cours de ce
discours de différentes manoeuvres qui
se seraient dessinés ces temps ci en
direction du centrisme et il n'a pas
indiqué clairement les sources mais tout
le monde sait bien qu'ils vont 7 au
milieu giscardien l'élément le plus
important de ce congrès se situe sans
doute là dans cette distance que
monsieur le caennais a voulu prendre ce
matin et dans cette résistance qu'il
entend opposer avec son mouvement à
toute tentative de récupération du
centrisme second de réunion politique du
week-end le comité directeur du parti
socialiste qui a publié ce matin une
déclaration importante
adopté à l'unanimité patricia charnolé
vous avez lu le texte que faut-il en
retenir et bien temple et le comité
directeur a déclaré qu'il ne fallait pas
se tromper d'adversaire le seul étanche
et le site la droite au pouvoir
mais en réalité les socialistes ont
entre les lignes répondu aux attaques du
parti communiste en se posant une fois
de plus comme les seuls et comme les
vrais défenseurs de l'union de la gauche
ce qui n'est pas vous l'imaginez pour
faire plaisir à leur partenaire
le parti socialiste a aussi tenu à
réaffirmer et ses plus importants sa
cohésion interne en approuvant comme
vous l'avez dit à l'unanimité la
résolution du comité directeur et c'est
je crois la seule nouveauté qu'il faut
retenir ce soir le parti socialiste face
à la désunion de la gauche semble résolu
à faire taire ces divergences
alors quelle va être la stratégie
socialiste dans la semaine dans les
semaines à venir et bien une ressemble
singulièrement à la stratégie du parti
communiste c'est à dire une gigantesque
campagne d'explication il faut expliquer
aux français les positions du parti
socialiste françois mitterrand va donc
battre la campagne va se rendre en
france dans toutes les assemblées de
militants
il faut aussi non seulement un parti uni
mais à parti plus fort et pour cela il
faut tout faire pour que l'air pour que
les français se rassemblent autour du
parti socialiste alors que dire ce soir
et bien les socialistes parlent d'un
rassemblement
les communistes l'ont dit hier il
revendique une gigantesque pression
populaire
il semble donc que l'ampleur des essais
de campagne parallèle et toutes les deux
très électorale rend peu probable une
reprise rapide des négociations
même si les socialistes se disent prêts
à reprendre sans préalable la discussion
les communistes viennent d'ailleurs de
réagir à cette proposition socialiste et
à l'ensemble du comité directeur
l'humanité de demain estime que le parti
socialiste n'a fait aujourd'hui
qu'opposer une fin de non recevoir aux
propositions du parti communiste vous le
voyez si on parle toujours d'union on
s'installe les deux côtés dans la
stratégie de la désunion
pour yves guéna le délégué politique du
rpr qui parlait cet après midi à laon le
crédit personnel de monsieur mitterrand
est aujourd'hui atteint ce jugement
monsieur hainard semble quelque peu au
sondage de l'ifop publié dans le point
cette semaine un sondage dans lequel 47%
des personnes interrogées pensent que
monsieur françois mitterrand voit ses
chances d'aller au pouvoir en mars 78
affaibli la dimension nationale entre
guillemette du premier min le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste est aussi
affaibli pense 32% des personnes
interrogées 26% pensent
renforcer en dehors du nouvel
observateur qui consacre sa couverture à
françois mitterrand avec la riposte
les autres êtres de madère par la vente
ou d'israël la solitude s'interroge
l'express en couverture cette semaine
valeurs actuelles parle de danger de
mort pour israël le point donc consacre
sa couverture aux villes les plus
écologiques de france et puis au passage
bienvenue dans les kiosques à deux
nouvelles publications jean et job un
bimensuel où l'on trouve beaucoup de
petites annonces
petites annonces comme du travail à
l'étranger par exemple et puis bd un
nouvel hebdomadaire de bandes dessinées
hebdo de la bd qui sera mis en vente
pour le premier numéro sera mis en vente
demain matin trois demoiselles en
représentation la petite reine la bécane
et la mob
ce n'est pas une fable c'est un langage
d'initier la traduction du 64ème salon
du cycle et du motocycle qui se tient à
paris à la porte de versailles du 7 au
17 octobre
en l'absence du salon de l'auto cette
année les deux ruf ont la vie belle
utilisé autant pour le travail que pour
les loisirs les deux roues font vivre en
france plus de cent mille personnes
si cette industrie est convalescente
après la crise de ces deux dernières
années l'engouement lui demeure auprès
du public symbole de cet engouement ces
deux bécane c'est l'expression qui ont
en commun d'être chacune la plus chère
dans sa catégorie
trente-deux mille francs pour cette moto
une belle américaine de tous sans
centimètres cubes
c'est le cheval de course dont rêvent
les passionnés jeunes et moins jeunes
celle ci aussi c'est un pur 112 vitesse
7 kg 700 championne du monde des poids
plume elle vaut dix mille francs
un bon vélo coûte 15 cents francs et
plus d'utilitaires randonneurs course ou
de mi course de mieux en mieux fini on
ne lésine pas sur un engin de détente et
de santé vont disent les médecins
de 7 à 77 ans et c'est le renouveau de
la petite reine avec les balades entre
amis le dimanche ou en vacances
nous avons acheté 2 millions de vélos en
1976 issue pour les neuf dixièmes de
l'hexagone les constructeurs français
s'inquiètent pourtant de la montée des
importations 30% l'an dernier et de la
baisse des exportations 20% les
excédents due aux exportations de vélo
ne couvre que le tiers du déficit dû aux
importations des deux roues à moteur
pour une moto fabriqué en france nous en
importons 200 japonaise pour les trois
quarts comme c'est suzuki yamaha
kawasaki plus de 20 mille francs pièce
de quoi se prendre le temps d'une virée
entre copains pour un champion du bol
d'or
quand on n'a pas les moyens on se rabat
sur les vélomoteurs on en trouve à
partir de 2000 francs la coqueluche
c'est la petite trial la moto verte une
nouvelle réglementation vise à créer
deux catégories de vélomoteurs l'une de
plus de 80 centimètres cubes
il faudra le permis moto l'autre en
dessous proche des cyclomoteurs la
réforme vient à point avec 6 millions de
cyclomoteurs nous avons le premier parc
mondial le vélo motorisé économe est une
invention française mais qui elle aussi
est menacée il reste deux grands
fabricants peugeot et motobécane lequel
a repris le troisième vélosolex le solex
900 et quelques francs c'est tout un
symbole comme la deux chevaux pour le
taux malgré les modifications les
couleurs pour les femmes en a vendu l'an
dernier huit fois moins qu'en 1964 et
une centaine de licenciements sont
annoncés dans l'entreprise alors avec
les cyclomoteurs les français vont ils
perdre un de leurs derniers ruban bleu
pourquoi cette chute en fait elle est dû
d'abord bien sûr à la conjoncture
générale qui n'étaient pas bonnes mais
surtout à une campagne extrêmement vives
qui a été menée qui avait pour objet
d'inciter les gens à accepter le port
obligatoire du casque et qui a donné
l'impression que le cyclomoteur et d un
véhicule dangereux
alors est ce vrai non ce n'est pas la
fin des lots solex malheureusement c'est
la fin avec tous les problèmes sociaux
que cela pose d'une usine est une
entreprise qui montaient les vélos solex
hélas elle les montaient en quantité
devenue insuffisante pour assurer sa
survie et la fabrication des vélos solex
va devoir être regroupées sur les usines
de saint quentin de motobécane et à ce
titre il a encore un avenir devant lui
mais qui est infiniment plus limité bien
sûr que celui de ses années de gloire
et puis à propos de motos fossiles
histoire étonnante contée par un
hebdomadaire espagnole ce week-end
profitant d'un moment de répit dans son
emploi du temps chargé
le roi juan carlos se seraient promenés
dans la banlieue de madrid sur une moto
le casque permettant au souverain de
garder l'incognito l'hebdomadaire va
peut-être un petit peu loin en
expliquant que ce motard royal voyant
l'un de ses collègues en panne d'essence
faisant de l'auto-stop l'a pris sur son
siège arrière et l'a emmené jusqu'à la
station service la plus proche
le roi lors mm raccompagné jusqu'à son
ange le motard n'a découvert l'identité
de son escorte qu'à la fin de l'histoire
lorsque le roi a ôté son casque pour le
saluer un récit de journalistes qui
ressemble fort à une légende en face et
quand même déception pas de légende
retour à la réalité pour le tir s'est
disputé à longchamp cet après-midi dans
la 4e course
bellino le 5 a gagné suivi de le
rayonnant le neuf et de magino le 11 5 9
et 11
voici d'ailleurs les rapports pour 5
francs dans l'ordre 1550 2 francs 50 et
dans un ordre différent 310 france 50
lots 12 étaient non-partants la météo
pour demain avant de se quitter
normalement elle devrait ressembler
comme deux gouttes d'eau à celle
d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire de la pluie
des nuages et des éclaircies surtout sur
les alpes et la méditerranée
ailleurs le temps sera variable les
averses devraient se localiser sur le
nord quelques rayons de soleil quand
même sur l'ouest le sud-ouest et le
centre où l'on fait en ce moment les
vendanges
je me retrouve avec plaisir vers 23h20
pour la dernière édition du journal je
vous souhaite une très belle soirée sur
antenne 2